every Wednesday our morning rounds looks
at medical issues that could affect you
and discusses solutions for better
health this morning there's a new
government warning about a serious polio
like illness that mainly strikes young
children we are entering peak season for
acute flaccid myelitis also known as afm
so far the CDC says there are 11
confirmed cases in eight states and more
are expected now last year's outbreak
infected a record 233 patients AFM can
cause paralysis and life-threatening
breathing problems we introduced you now
to a seven-year-old sebastian Bottomly
last year the illness paralyzed him and
our doctor new rule is here was more on
this story I guess the question now is
Tara how is Sebastian doing these days
yes well Sebastian's story Gale shows us
the overwhelming impact of this rare
illness he's been through more than
2,000 hours of physical therapy and
still struggles to walk almost three
years after being diagnosed it's been a
long road and it's a still an ongoing
process
Sebastian's mother Krista Bottomly says
her son's journey began in 2016 when his
cold turned into the polio like illness
leaving him paralyzed from the neck down
we were there for Sebastian's fight to
walk again
in 2018 here 'i learned to dress eat and
stand by himself but now learning to
walk again is a slow grueling process
while he's able to move most of his body
after all the work that we've done it is
still a struggle for him to walk he it's
if we have to go distances he mostly was
in the wheelchair since Sebastian became
sick he's been an intensive rehab
everyday he feels very frustrated when
he remembers what he used to be able to
do and now he can't but he's also
feeling excited about what
learn to be able to do it's been a long
journey to get here but I think he's
feeling encouraged and hopeful it's good
to see him Tara good to have you at the
table so let's start with what causes
AFM and what is it spike in the summer
well it's a little bit of a mystery
still you know the CDC is working very
hard to figure that out and the best
theory we have is that it may be caused
by a family of viruses known as the
enterovirus family and so the idea is
that that virus specifically attacks the
motor neurons in the spinal cord that
causes the weakness it also could be an
inflammatory and immune reaction to the
virus that's damaging those nerves but
one of the questions is why does it
affect some kids and not others so if
the virus is in the same family one
sibling might get this and the other one
doesn't so there are a lot of questions
and we're not sure why it has this kind
of biennial pattern where it spikes
every other year we do see it in the
fall and summer months we think again
maybe this is because enterovirus
circulates during that time what are the
symptoms to so symptoms to look for
would be usually children have had an
acute respiratory illness or a fever in
the month preceding and then they
develop sudden onset weakness and
paralysis of the arms or legs they can
also have a facial droop they can have
trouble speaking or swallowing or
difficulty moving their eyes and the big
concern is if it affects the respiratory
muscles they can have trouble breathing
and that can happen very quickly where
they may end up on a ventilator in fact
in this series of numbers the CDC
released about 20 to 30% did require
ventilatory support 60% required
admission to the ICU what's the typical
treatment and what are the long-term
prognosis for these kids well aside from
not understanding the cause we really
don't have a great treatment other than
supportive care and so as we saw in the
piece really intensive physical therapy
and Rehab is kind of the primary
treatment we have tried things like
steroids plasma for rhesus
immunoglobulin therapy but none of those
are really been shown to work so it's a
big question at this point and you know
the long-term recovery also questionmark
some kids have had a long-term paralysis
months or years after this all right
scary stuff Tara thank you very much